good morning to you Kenny it's so good
to see you I read about this song then
it came to you in a dream and I'm
thinking you need to dream more often my
friend what did you see it was the
craziest thing was like um last Saturday
and I was just I just had a dream that
we were at our house in Vegas and I was
playing the guitar and playing some
chords for and started saying I'm in a
melody and asked her I mean what do you
think of this and she said that's pretty
good boy and I mind you I've never asked
her opinion on any of my music over the
years I would never do that and so it's
just funny that it happened in a dream
yeah and I love the picture that you
chose to to go with the video of your
mother I can imagine a lot of people are
looking at this video Kenny and it
brings back a lot of memories especially
for those who no longer have our mothers
that's why I think people are so touched
and if you have your mother this is also
a good reminder of what you have in your
life no question it's uh you know when I
was just listening to it there it's it's
a funny song because it does hit me
every time and it was a little hard to
record it actually so but it was um it
was nice it was a it was a good feeling
it made me feel closer you know it's
taken you five years to release a new
song and I know you've been writing why
did you think now is the time because
you write all the time well yeah I do
write a lot but I I'm I also it takes a
long time for me to decide on something
and and actually I decided on one thing
to do and then it just didn't feel right
ultimately and then you know she gave me
I feel like mom gave me this gift you
know to come with something that was
heartfelt and you know and there's only
there's only one other song that I wrote
like that and that was the song of the
day and so I don't usually dream of the
songs and we go write them yeah yeah I
remember the day when your son when your
son was born so mother's day you're
gonna release a song you're hosting an
Instagram live event what are you
planning well
when I did the vs. battle with Teddy I
kept on saying a lot of comments about
people wanting to hear music from
Waiting to Exhale and of course I
couldn't play it at that time so I
thought it would be great to you know
play the music of Waiting to Exhale tell
the stories tell talk about the artists
and and how it all came together and if
I get enough in order that I might play
even play this song live you know and if
I could make it through it
please do that Kenny please do that
Waiting to Exhale it's a big anniversary
I think it's 25 years or something that
was one of my favorite movies and the
music from that still holds up today but
you mentioned Teddy Riley because you
guys had a big I don't even like to call
it a battle it was it was it was a
competition between the two of you and
it was so fun to watch on Instagram over
4 million people watched it it crashed
Instagram a couple of times what was
that like for you because it must have
taken you back to a very special place
it was it was amazing to to be able to
play the music and to to know to see so
many people show up for it I mean I
don't know that we we we expect the
bands and that was the best feeling that
so many people came came out the world
stopped and they stopped to listen to
our music because I say all the time
that music is healing listen Michelle
Obama Jennifer Lopez a lot of people
stopped by that day just to see what the
two of you are doing and I've heard you
say this I love this Kenny that there
are two things that make you feel good a
chicken sandwich especially I highly
recommend the popeyes chicken sandwich
two things make you feel good a chicken
sandwich and a good song what's the
difference between the two for you why
do they make you feel good I love that
sentence well you know chicken
sandwiches Duke in the right one can you
always make you feel good make you feel
like you're home but a song can take you
anywhere to any place in any time and
and sometimes we need an escape and this
is a good time to have an escape yeah we
all need an escape I also know that you
and your lovely wife Nikki got kovin 19
you're both survived you're both healthy
it's a different
ference for everybody I read your
started with a sore throat a tickle in
your throat you went to the doctor but
then it took a turn for the worst what
what happened to you yeah it it was just
a sore throat at first and I thought
that's all it was gonna be but then that
that evening it turned into a fever and
turned to the sweats and body aches and
the whole bit and lasted for about five
six days of the the fever just non-stop
and and even after five or six days it
would the fever would come back a little
bit so you thought you were out of it
but it just kind of kept hanging around
so and the biggest thing is that you you
worry about whether it's going to go to
the next level because you don't know
you have no idea so fortunately we were
blessed in Nicki's her it was completely
different for her we are blessed we are
blessed that you were both here and I
think it's an important reminder that
most people that get it actually survive
it you know people get very frightened
by it but most people actually survive
it and you're living proof of that yeah
Kenny I can't wait for Sunday I will be
there and I can't wait to hear you sing
the song something tells me you're gonna
do it you're gonna do it cheering you on
Kenny
always good to see you baby face still
fits you at 62 you still got that baby
face thank you very much